[تصفيق]
راح نخشع الموصل من اجمل المدن بالعراق بس
اذا شغلايه اللخ معاها اللي هي يهتمون
ايضا
بالمستشفيات والصحه يهتمون
يعني
الملاعب الرياضيه يهتمون بالكهرباء يهتمون
يعني البطاقه التموينيه وتوزيعها على
المواطنين
المدينه تظهر جميله عندما يكونون ناسها
مرتاحين
[تصفيق]
هذا المشروع بالذات ياتي لفقد فك
الاختناقات المروريه
وربط الطريق الواصل من تقاطع النبي يونس
باتجاه جامعه الموصل وحي المهندسين وحي
الزراعي
لتسهيل حركه مرور المركبات
[تصفيق]
اريد مستشفيات هسه المرضى ما يروحون
للبصره يتعالجون يروحون للشمال يتعالجون
احنا نريد مستشفيات نريد نريد مشاريع نشوف
يعني مشاريع تنقذ المدينه تنقذ البطاله
والعطاله داخل المدينه مشاريع الاستثماريه
بدانا بمرحله اعمار تشمل الدوائر الحكوميه
وتشميل البرد التحتيه الطرق الجسور
المناطق الترفيهيه ايصال الخدمات الى جميع
مناطق المحافظه اليوم في بلديه الموصل
اصبح مدينه الموصل يحتذى بها ويشار اليها
في سرعه اعاده الاعمار
[تصفيق]